(upbeat music)
- Hi, I'm Alvin.
Welcome back to Tasty's "Making it Big".
Today, I'm gonna be making a
giant Popeyes chicken sandwich,
because I've actually
never had the real one
until last week.
And I just wanted to see
what the hype was about.
I thought it was pretty good
the first time I had it.
So thought it could be fun
to make a giant fried chicken sandwich.
And not only a giant
fried chicken sandwich
but the Popeyes one.
So enough talk, let's get going.
So we are first going to get
started with the big bun.
I have yeast, some warm milk,
and we have to add in little bit of sugar
for the yeast to eat.
A sprinkling of flour and mix.
You go hang out over
there. Thank you, dude.
Now we have.
I don't know if you guys remember
from the previous seasons
of "Making it Big",
we had a stand mixer named Todd.
Unfortunately, Todd couldn't make it.
We put him through a little too much work
and he is now in the
KitchenAid scrap yard.
So we have a new one.
I will christen it with a new name.
This mixer's name shall be known
as Bertha from here on out.
And we're going to start making the dough.
This is a Bertha's first maiden voyage.
So we're going to put in a lot of flour.
Stop spilling, Alvin.
Some sugar, salt.
Just gonna give a little mix.
I like that we have the clear bowl
so that you guys can see what's going on.
In goes the eggs.
Bloob, bloob, bloob, bloob, bloob.
That's the sound eggs make.
(turns on)
Ooh, it's a beat.
(keeps turning on and off)
Yeah. Here we go.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, Bertha, calm down now.
I locked you in the back
or are you still going up?
It's okay.
It's kinda like, suppress Bertha
while she mixes this dough.
All right, let's see how this yeast.
Ooh. It grew up a little bit.
Slowly going in. Hell, calm
down, Bertha, simmer down now.
Better not spray any of that up at me.
I'm gonna be mad, Bertha.
I'm gonna speed this up a little bit.
(intense whirring)
(mixing sound)
So it'd be a good time
to scrape down the sides.
Woo. That is some gluten.
Hello. Good job Bertha. You're killing it.
Back in you go. Lock.
Now we have the butter
that you're gonna add
in little by a little.
Honestly, I could probably
watch this all day.
It's like watching a gif,
but instead of looping,
it's free, 'cause it
keeps going on its own.
That's nice. I like free things.
Oh, the dough's getting nice and glossy.
Bertha is heating up.
Now that all the butter is in,
this thing's to go at speed
three for about five minutes.
And you know what, we all
had the mile test in PE.
Well stand mixers have the brioche test,
'cause I got to do this for five minutes,
so keep up the good work.
So Bertha's actually getting quite hot.
I can almost cook an egg on this thing
and well you look at this,
this is a, it's a tornado.
Bertha's got that stupid
thick brioche going on.
Look at that. Oh my god.
Here we can go.
Wooo.
That's pretty.
(slams)
That's how you know it's ready.
All this dough is stuck
to the hook. Look at that.
Oh my god, that's beautiful.
Good job Bertha. You killed it.
You go rest over there.
Good job.
Look at this.
It just. That's some crazy
cool gluten. Look at that.
All right, some flour.
It's like liquid dough.
You guys ever play with like slime
or the thing that you make in school
with like the corn starch.
This is what it's like.
All right. We're gonna get you in here.
Nice.
Okay. This guy's in here.
Gotta let this proof
and we'll be right back.
All right. So our little brioche baby
has grown up quite a bit.
And we're going to punch
our baby in the face.
(punches)
Ow.
Alright. Get this guy out.
Whoa. That's awesome. It's like honeycomb.
Gotta get this into a nice
ball 'cause he's sticky.
Now I know why they
call it a bench scraper.
This is a quite troublesome baby.
We're just gonna have to yolo this one.
(laughs)
Please don't treat your kids like that.
If you're a professional
baker or work in the industry,
feel free to roast how bad I did that.
But on this show, we do what we can.
So this is going to proof,
and then we're going to put in the oven.
And so we have here,
two large, not chicken,
because turkey made a lot more sense.
We have two very large turkey breasts.
It also has the beautiful,
delicious skin on it,
which I think is great.
So even though this is a
Popeyes chicken sandwich,
I won't tell if you don't.
But this is a Turkey sandwich.
Right. So I'm gonna go in here,
get that nice butterfly going.
When you're butterflying
something like this,
you got to check your work.
It's like in school when
you do the math problems.
All right, that's one.
We're going to do one.
Or we're going to do two.
Check your work.
All right. I skewer this together.
Get in like that. And
then we got to go down.
Then we can go up. There we go.
Let's check if we can lift
it and if it holds together.
This is one of the two,
because Popeyes chicken sandwich
has a good amount of meat.
And I don't like to skimp on meat
when it comes to these sorts of dishes.
So I'm gonna make another one of these
and we will be right back.
So we are going to bread our
beautiful turkey breasts.
And in order to do that,
we've got to make a seasoned flour mixture
to get as much flavor
in there as possible.
I'm not sure if this is
the exact same recipe
that Popeyes uses.
'Cause you know, then I could
run them out of business.
We got seasoning, we got some salt, flour,
some pepper, paprika.
Whoa, that smells nice.
Whoa, that's spicy.
Cayenne and paprika.
Slowly give that a whisk.
I'm going to go in here.
We are using large cake pans
as our breading stations.
This is making it big
and where the unconventional
is conventional.
Shout out to Home Depot.
Evenly mixed, no big lumps.
And this is buttermilk for the chicken.
You got to season your chicken, heavily.
Make sure it tastes good. Got
the salt, some nice pepper.
Large piece of meat
needs a lot of seasoning.
You know when chicken
or turkey is seasoned
when it stops looking
like its original form.
Into the flour.
The largest breading
situation I've ever done.
It's like making a zen garden.
The buttermilk, nice, good coat.
Back in the flour.
Some nice crackles going on.
Right in here.
And this is going to be a
nicely breaded piece of chicken.
I mean turkey. I mean chicken.
Whoa. This is one big chicken,
turkey, I mean chicken.
All right. This is my chicken sandwich.
And that's one. That was fun.
I'm gonna do another one and
we're gonna go fry this thing.
Happy Halloween.
Popeyes chicken sandwich
does come with a sauce
and we're going to make a spicy mayo,
which is one of the most
complicated recipes there is.
'Cause he got to put mayo and spicy.
We got hot sauce.
Contrary to my Chinese roots,
I'm not a big spice tolerant person.
So I'm gonna,
yeah that's spicy.
I'm just only going to do a little bit.
Nobody tell, especially my mom.
She would disown me.
Yeah, I don't know.
I think I would like to say
that my negative affinity
towards spice is a,
it's a good defense
evolutionary mechanism.
Not that I just can't eat at restaurants
and I'm a wuss when I eat
a pepper or hot cheetos.
I like to tell myself that
it's a good, it's a good thing.
It's going to help me in the long run.
Spicy mayo. Very easy.
You put mayo and you put spicy together
and you have spicy mayo.
I want to go bake the bun now.
Okay. So this little guy has been proofing
for quite a while.
I got to put the baby in the oven.
That's a word no one should
ever say. In you go dude.
Nice and big. Woo.
Okay. Baby's in the oven.
I'm going to fry some chicken.
The heat is radiating.
I'm about to do something very dangerous.
Please do not do this at home.
We have very, very hot oil,
one breaded chicken, turkey, chicken patty
that I made earlier and a dream.
And we're going to fry this.
But please, do not ever do this
because we have trained
professionals onset.
All right, here we go.
Don't do this at home, ever.
(sizzling)
That is cool. Woo.
Okay, so our big patty is in there.
I'm pretty sure this
isn't how Popeyes does it,
but I'm pretty happy with this.
Woohoohoo.
It's a crust right there.
It's kind of funny how much
heat this thing is radiating.
I can feel it all the way from here.
My face is really nice and warm.
And this, it's kinda like
camping, like a campfire.
Okay, so I'm looking for a
pretty good golden brown crust,
but I also want the
chicken, turkey, chicken
to cook through.
I don't know why I keep saying that.
Now we're committed.
It kinda reminds me of the
chicken nugget episode we did.
Looking pretty good.
Might need to finish this guy in the oven.
Look at that crust.
That's a nice, that's a nice crust.
We are coming out.
That is one patty.
All right, that's one. I
have to do another one.
This is going into the oven
so we can finish cooking it through.
So it has been 50 minutes, almost an hour.
And it is time to take
my baby out of the oven.
Oh man, that is one,
this is one smooth, beautiful baby.
I hope my baby in the
future looks like this.
That's nice. Okay.
This bun is done.
I'm very proud of this bun.
(smells)
That smells nice.
We are now ready to assemble.
We have a toasted bun that
has been sliced in half.
Toasted with butter 'cause toasted buns
make a world of a difference.
Three big turkey, chicken, turkey patties.
Culinary team was gracious
enough to help me make two
while I was a manhandling
this first one over here.
We have pickles, spicy mayo
that we did make earlier.
I think, ain't nothing
to it, but to just do it.
According to Google images,
the Popeyes chicken sandwich
does start off with a layer of the mayo.
Gonna get that on here.
Yeah, that's some nice sauce.
Nice ASMR.
And now the chicken.
We've gotta get you over there.
This is awesome.
One.
Two.
Oh my God. That's what I'd like to see.
And three.
Ooh.
I gotta get the skewer out.
Come on.
Got it.
Pickles.
This might take a minute.
This is going to be quite fun.
Oh wait the pickles are
supposed to go on the bottom.
Whatever. I totally forgot.
I kind of liked them better on top.
Don't know why there was such a craze
when this first came out.
There were fights over this.
People were brawling on them streets.
And they're probably
fighting over that right now.
That chicken's gonna absorb all
this pickle juice real nice.
All right. That should be
a good for the pickles.
Now.
Let's see.
I'm going to put on a little
bit more sauce for the top.
Right. Top bun. Yeah.
Well that's quite a large
Popeyes chicken sandwich.
I want to clean up a bit
and then we're going to finally dig in.
But man, I'm excited to eat this.
We have one large chicken sandwich
and we have one large knife.
There's only one thing we have to do now.
Oh, may the force be with me?
(slicing sound)
You guys hear that.
Damn.
Hoohoooo.
Oh my God. Look at how good this bun is.
It's like a pillow.
Look at this cross section.
Look at these layers.
Look good this. Someone tag Popeyes.
I will take little edge piece.
Little as in the size of a cake.
This bun is so good.
This knife is so good.
It's the super slicer.
And the chicken is still juicy.
As you can see, I mean the
turkey, I mean the chicken.
How does one eat?
Come on.
Divide this in two.
There's like seven people
staring at me right now.
This is hilarious.
Hmmm.
It's pretty good.
Tastes like the chicken
sandwich from Popeyes.
I did not expect it to be
this good. What the heck?
I'm going to keep eating
this for a few minutes.
Yeah, so I, my piece, it
was actually tastier than,
and closer to the actual chicken sandwich
than I had thought.
I think the most exciting
thing about this for me
is the bread. It's spongy.
It's buttery. It's
delicious. It's brioche.
The chicken and the
turkey. The turkey chicken.
It's great. It's juicy.
The pickles are nice. The mayo is nice.
I could see why people may or may not
get into a physical
altercation over the sandwich.
#worldstar.
Oh yeah. This was fun.
I cannot wait to spend
the next couple of days
with this sandwich.
And that being said,
thank you for watching.
I'll see you guys next time.
(upbeat music)